der flug schon bereit an bord 7
asylsuchende unter ihnen um war geflohen
aus iran vor folter und gefängnis es
gelingt uns mit ihnen kontakt
aufzunehmen
alle die in diesem flieger saßen klagen
über psychische probleme können nachts
nicht mehr schlafen
es fühlte sich an wie auf dem weg zur
eigenen hinrichtung erzählt er gegen
seinen willen nach ruanda dem ziel der
chartermaschine in letzter minute
verhindert der europäische gerichtshof
für menschenrechte den start um avid
zurückgebracht in die abschiebe
einrichtung blockhaus
die stimmen schreie der anderen hier
wecken mich auf wir sind immer in alarm
stellung haben angst davor was als
nächstes passieren wird denn nun
entscheiden die gerichte ob britanniens
neue härte rechtens ist er doch
abgeschoben wird
ich habe es schon oft gesagt ruanda wäre
mein ende ich könnte nicht mehr
weiterleben
oma ist einer von 30.000
bootsflüchtlingen die im vergangenen
jahr über den ärmelkanal gekommen sind
in gummibooten als kurde im iran
politisch verfolgt sein onkel ermordet
erzählt er er wollte zu seiner schwester
die nicht erkannt werden will aus angst
vor anfeindungen der nachbarn schon vor
20 jahren ist sie nach england geflohen
ihr bruder könne bei ihr unterkommen
würde niemandem zur last fallen sie ist
noch immer fassungslos
er saß in dieser maschine rief mich an
hörst du mich alle um ihn herum schrien
und weinten
mein bruder auch er flehte dass man ihn
nicht nach ruanda schicken dürfe selbst
die sicherheitsleute sagten sie wollen
es nicht machen es war die hölle die
ganze familie war fertig mit den nerven
tränenüberströmt wir hatten keine ahnung
was wir tun sollten ich hoffe dass
niemals mehr irgend jemand so etwas
erfahren
doch genau auf diese erfahrung bauen die
britische regierung und premier johnson
ihre neue asylpolitik abschreckung wer
auf illegalem weg kommt kann ausgeflogen
werden
darf nur in ruanda asyl beantragen was
selbst bei einem positiven bescheid
heißt die neue heimat wird ostafrika
dieser innovative ansatz getrieben von
dem uns gemeinsamen humanitären antrieb
möglich durch die freiheiten des brh
exit wird asylsuchenden legale routen
eröffnen und das geschäftsmodell der
schleuser zerstören
welche legalen roten frack thomas anwalt
flüchtlinge aus kriegs und
krisengebieten könnten bis auf wenige
ausnahmen nur auf britischen insel boden
asyl beantragen
warum würde jemand die harte und
gefährliche reise auf sich nehmen wenn
er auch legal kommen kann
wir plädieren dafür dass die regierung
ein gesetz formuliert dass das
flüchtlingen ermöglicht in einem
drittstaat asyl in großbritannien zu
beantragen
stattdessen kommen sie mit diesem
lächerlichen gesetz um die ecke dass die
menschen einfach in ein anderes land
verfrachtet chips people of another
country die ganze absurdität ergänzte
der anwalt für einwanderungsrecht zeige
sich in ruanda kigali die hauptstadt sei
bereit für die ankömmlinge
internationalen medien werden deren
hotels präsentiert so gut würden sie es
hier haben zu freunden werden herberge
der hoffnung heißt eine der unterkünfte
ganz im sinne der regierung
wir machen das aus den richtigen bewegt
unten haben die erfahrung ruanda als die
willkommen die aus schwierigen
verhältnissen zu uns kommen und wir sind
entschlossen das abkommen umzusetzen
laut vereinten nationen
menschenrechtlern und einem report der
britischen regierung selbst sieht die
realität anders aus als eines der
ärmeren länder der welt habe ruanda kaum
ressourcen um faire asylverfahren zu
stemmen keine übersetzer etwa dass die
hunderte millionen von euro die london
für den abschiebe deal überweist
größtenteils für flüchtlinge verwendet
werden fraglich
luanda bewege sich nicht in richtung
demokratie sondern diktatur presse und
meinungsfreiheit unter beschuss der deal
mit den briten nicht der erste versuch
israel hatte 4000 einwanderer geschickt
die sich alle wieder auf den weg zurück
gemacht hatten und auch in libyen
gestrandete flüchtlinge nahe kigali
untergebracht mit eu-geldern wollen vor
allem eins der nach rom da kommt
verschwindet wieder so schnell kann die
flüchtlinge sind nicht im gefängnis wir
erschaffen ein katz und maus system noch
mehr geld für die schleuser noch längere
gefährlichere wege für flüchtlinge die
es immer wieder versuchen modems die
abschreckung funktionieren nicht die
kosten so hoch dass es ein sonder
dekrete innenministerin brauchte für
eine praxis die die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention
unterläuft die der künftige könig heißt
es entsetzlich finde die die
versammelten bischöfe des landes als
unmoralische schande brandmarken und
glaubt man der opposition die nur ein
ziel hat
es funktioniert nicht es ist unethisch
es stoppt die menschenschmuggler nicht
sie als innenministerin lassen sich
nicht beirren geben noch mal eine halbe
million pfund für einen charterflug aus
von dem sie nie glaubten dass er abheben
würde alles was sie interessiert ist der
politische kampf sündenböcke wie etwa
gerichte zu finden harmloses aufplustern
es geht nicht um konsensfähige lösungen
sondern um spaltung regieren wird so zur
lachnummer
stimmung machen wähler mobilisieren für
einen premier der skandal am laufenden
band produziert zwei nach wahlen zum
unterhaus drohen ihn in dieser woche
weiter zu beschädigen dass eine
britische regierung für das politische
überleben die menschenrechte von
flüchtlingen mit füßen treten könnte das
galt mal als undenkbar